this video is brought to you by expressvpn
and Shopify people more on them after the
reaction what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to continue Reacher
season 2 episode 4 today John how are you jacked
up I am jacked up or Ro wait man oh you're a
NE swan song of puns thisit we shooting
this not in the am but the PM anyway guys
we've remembered character names I think
listen everyone it would be great if you
could leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated also tell us in the
comments what are your thoughts on episode 4
be sure to subscribe click the notification
Bell cuz we are going of course cover the
rest of Reacher season 2 thank you to all
have join us at our patreon page for Reacher
and for also you know being understanding to
our open opinions if we are critical about some
things you know I know this is a very sensitive
show for people people are very sensitive about
their violence full L Reaction watch single with
your own copy of reer do available for super
sexy Rejects and over there John and I cover
several things exclusively with high list
and watch Longs included John let's get into
action go to Jack Diner I got nothing too no
new information well I wouldn't say we haven't
found any new information damn look at all that
brand deals look someone's got to say it was Swan
working with these guys or with these guys Swan's
not dirty Swan's totally dirty come on reard one
of them has to be you don't think there's even
a chance no I don't focus on what we found yeah
can't doubt a member of the 1110th no matter
what joke I made a minute ago Brad Stacy this
is a brad that is a Fastener Jack Fastener Brad
Reacher Shane l director of security maybe he's
a guy I got on the phone in Atlantic City he's
a security boss and bosses give orders and the
guys we killed had orders to take us out just a
theory it's really specific good theory aren't
you the guy that said that assumptions kill well
you're assuming that Swan's the same guy was back
in the 110 oo this is the guy Richard chased
down outside of cian's house associate Security
Officer he was a security officer maybe there's a
reason new age has so many security issues don't
forget Marlo Burns she knew she was sending us
right into a buz saw when she gave us europian
address that [__] we got over 1,000 employees
how are we going to tackle that machine gun yeah
let's get them all in a headlock one at a time one
at a time there a lot of patience at the 110 100
episodes later that was a good opening scene yeah
I like how there's forming a tension between them
and an hour later the place is hit with a smash
and grab do you know how that makes this apartment
look like we're five steps behind everything I
made those applications when I had enough for
a warrant looks like Wilson Fisk he does this his
Origins who's the monster and I'll bet you that it
is those Tin Soldiers that you were supposed to
be keeping your black eye on it wasn't the Army
brats I made it crystal clear to them not to color
outside the line so they listened I bet you gave
them the crayons and everything you thought
if you told them nicely that play along your
NYPD these are Pi for Christ sakes it is this
too much for you Russo Lieutenant all fairness
they immediately disobeyed would you please go
and find out what they learned right am I asking
you nicely enough Russo damn I'm just trying to
do the right thing you know I just trying to do
the right thing get your at me check it's making
me agitated who put this song on you got beef with
the Talking Heads we're in New York they're a
New York band they're a Rhode Island band that
moved to New York and no I don't have a beef with
them ouch Ro to Nowhere when we're sitting here
getting nowhere it's a good ironic pull I might
have something I've been scrubbing the drives for
everything Swan related and Marlo Burns David burn
he's the assistant director of security so all of
his emails have lsten his boss and a half dozen
other security personnels you seed on them mean
they a team they share information but he didn't
share everything yeah multiple emails between Swan
and our old friend Marlo Burns just them no one
else copied how about what music messages I was
listening to an album the other day thought you
might like it Jimmy Hendrick axis bold as love
axis bold as love Swan hated Hendrix Swan became
dewy Finn skinnard no Hendrix no Zeppelin No who I
mean that was his rule he's leaving everyone else
off the email saying he loved something we know he
hated they did have that very specific flashback
about the guitar songs yeah says the sixth track
is called little hold on he's in this table file
on a federal defense project called Little Wing
by far the biggest contract ever had four times
the size of anything I've seen anywhere else in
their records h a nine figure contract people
murdered for Less look at this in her office
who's that seems a test for the Ling Tech sell for
some military breast even a senator but what kind
of test and where and how can I get it Senator
Malcolm Lavoy assured he would do all he could
to get the Congressional votes to make little
wing a reality and I quote he fully believes
in the work we're doing here at New Age and we'll
do whatever it takes to help us whatever it takes
you know this guy by reputation in DC Lavoy what's
known as a paper bag his politics and his vote go
whichever way the winds blowing ouch so if New Age
stands to make a fortune on a government contract
and Lavoy is its champion in Congress it stands
to reason new age is the wind blowing the voice
bag that sounds wrong so Swan who's missing Maybe
dirty Maybe not is code texting Marlo Burns who
tried to have us killed about a program supported
by an ethically compromised politician thank you
thank you some that information was a little hard
to keep up with really appreciate you there Dixon
English please paage bills a legislative record
they don't read that stuff they just vote the
way they're told to but as legislative director
they're the guys who actually craft and draft the
laws which is good for us because those guys have
no security detail oo that wow that seems like it
should be different why would those people talk
to us I can make it so they' be begging to tell
us what they know oh this is your episode
man there's a lot of powerful people in DC
with uh confidential problems things they do in
private that they'd rather not get made public my
job is to make sure that their personal business
stays personal I need to hire you oh yeah you're
a fixer hey you give me 10 minutes to make some
phone calls I'll get the name of the legislative
director and an ailles heel o they're playing
dirty dirt Reacher clean if he wasn't he wouldn't
have disappeared like the rest of the guys but
he didn't disappear like the rest of the guys
his body was never found his place wasn't trash
he bought a Hendrick's album he ran off so fast
because he knew three pissed off soldiers and
a Kaiju were coming for him Reacher Legacy of
monster I would love love that maybe we don't know
some people as well as we think we do there's no
way the Tony Swan I recruited is a part of this
but this is a reflection on me you're judging
me I take full responsibility for his actions
in the present there's still a hell of a lot
of work ahead more rest to be made infrastructure
dismantle whole networks of cargo plays jeeps and
helicopters across three continents can we go back
investigation you can you could probably discover
a there so much more money I can make oh dude
cut me in on that looks like we got some Ivory
soap over here Reacher meaning this [__] so pure
and floats how pure 99% Heisenberg let me try it
yeah it's quite the buying bust kilos of poison
and a handful of scumbag dealers off the streets
these are the small fish we'll catch the shark
soon enough I want to see Reacher take a shark
so this has got to be the case that's caught up
to them in the present right yeah it's got to be
something to do with this 20 months already into
his terrible to apparently he's a prodigy talking
about a prodigy you're about to hit your bicardi
milstone 151 cases closed damn cardi reach how
much is 48 brickworth anyway 47 one's missing
there's 47 not 48 in an investigation Details
Matter hey hey I said that's my quote now I
know we loaded 48 bricks into Swan's ride oh
what let's check your car what wow sounds like
this flashback could have been brought up by
other people solved I was saving this for later
Fallen back there when I was driving and gotten
stuck that's the first rounds on me tonight for
that I don't know man talk about a up yeah slack
Reacher losing a key of H I'd say that's worth
two rounds ne's been suspicious forever and Jack's
been like I recruited him I mean he doesn't
make mistakes I make no poor assessments ever
of people no he did a thorough job there never a
character twist in my life my gut tells me he's
a good man your gut's never been wrong before
gut Reacher you just say things now don't even
rhyme it doesn't have to rhyme the syllables can
work as well it's about the meter according to
a top comment in our last video all right only
Rhymes poetry is only rhyme let's just see what
odonnell found yeah let's see what odonnell found
apparently odonnell found just a syllable is good
enough now for our puns it's about the meter
as much as it is the r okay oh my gosh wow wow
I read your intake and upon first glance I got
to say got a few questions when you're quite a
handsome fell now I'm not here to tell you how to
live your life but are you really certain you want
me to give you a new face I only take on ugly
people yeah in a manner of speaking wow now do
the surgery yes yeah while someone else is doing
a surgery to fix this wound on you when you're a
doctor you know what's happening your trick here
is separate blood is entering your lungs you're
drowning your brain is deprived of oxygen oh my
god I've always wanted to kill someone like this
where you're like telling them what's happening
to them as they dying oh now you can't hear me
now I am you you're dead beautiful continue the
monologue though this is the most hilarious plan
I've ever seen guys he saw an advertisement in the
in middle of a very serious situation and when I'm
just going to pretend to be him that's how good he
is he just sets himself up for success by winding
up in these situations best flat ever I love
it I want a whole spin-off where he just takes
over this guy's life Daniel Boyd Senator Lavoy
legislative director spoiled [__] who's never
lifted anything heavier than a Grey Goose bottle
in his life Gray Goose gray Reacher I did it you
know I'm going to go back and call some of these
and I'm going to come up with detailed defenses
and now he drafts legislation that decides to
fade of the Free World telling his boss to vote
on whatever benefits the lobbyist who woed him
best so he was born somewhere between third and
home base and never heard the word consequence
still got the casino shirt Boyd's going to be
in Boston tonight for a fundraiser event at
the pops we'll set him up like a bowling pin
come on can't ghost people Jack oh you pick up
the phone I thought maybe you couldn't answer
because you broke your hand when you drove the
[__] car through the office building I didn't
get hurt at all the car belong belonged to one
of their employees I was returning yep yep yep
yep I want everything you got on new AG that's
why I answered the phone this time I actually
have a reason to talk to you I'm going to send
you their security team roster run background
check see what connections these guys have Jack
Checker before we head north uh Dixon and I should
go talk to Marlo Burns step on her neck a little
bit address is online while we do all the work
what are you guys going to do oh we're going to
go score some drugs yeah crackery hey not bad not
bad I thought it 20 minutes ago yeah and I forgot
to say it earlier see start scripting them out in
advance we looks like Brad pther
ow yeah were we walking in Fight
Club save that for later find a new
line of work [__] yeah man jack [__]
reer now you're just mocking me G now
you're just mocking me oh good shot
though I want them to just walk in the house and
go oh nothing let's go after this amazing shot
wow this really is like an amazing shot
drones a really open it's like a real
estate commercial damn that amazing
shot a lightly used Craftsman mini
Mansion who sent those Roses or FL flowers
cereal yeah hey what's in the get out here
we got what need I need the proofs of purchase
someone's scamming the prize system she's got
a kid oh a kid take the well I sure yeah house
clear affirmative wow one 10 really doesn't keep
in touch with each other no didn't even know
I had a kid mean just some expensive jewelry
Marlo Left Behind think she bugged out oh Marlo
thought this was someone else Jane's a gamer o
what we got we got Crash Bandicoot yeah she said
Kaiju earlier and just kaai you on the wall yeah
look at that kids kids behind this $50 million
thank you for your business Dr we have a wonderful
Drive oh say something cool a little girl
what is this sensitivity with with the
children that he applies it's a very unique
character trait do you know why I love comic
books so much here we go mom mom didn't
give a [__] it's cuz his parents were
both killed at the comic book store hey
where are the clothes you wearing garbage
garbage why I'm already carrying boots
if I had any more clothes pretty soon
I need a suitcase I got a suitcase I need a
house to keep it in and I need a car for the
driveway anyone ever diagnosed
you as a sociopath diagnosed
no like their awkward chemistry the not one
word holy [__] you I'm just saying you look
nice you both look nice you look like the [__]
on top of a wedding cake pay you back in a month
when my pension land your won't cover that
suit or the hotel room or the plane ticket
I'll pay you back in two months I got good
Pion e no guys stop everyone ready let's
go listen to some boring ass music let's do
that oh I know oh your mouth BOS your catchup
flies oh I hope she's on the level I like how
he's stunned like as it already yeah but it's
such a braz i' never noticed how like oh my God
he's feeling awkward in front of the team it's
not saying you can't admire her being awe of
her beauty in the move but it was like stunned
in a way as if he has like whoa I've never
realized I found you this attractive before
man his grew three sizes today I don't know if
I have orchestra seats or floor box seats and
I actually don't even know what that means you
mind the mezanine that's where you are but that
just simply won't cut it you see you want to be
down here oh the sound just wraps around you like
a fleece wow why would I swap your ticket with
my Aid when he arrives wouldn't he mind not if
he wants to keep his job please take a seat it's
how I broker all my deals in Washington that a
quit got 13 14s 813 over 7 months 6 day working
weeks maybe a time sheet clock in hours maybe a
rating scale I don't know this is why chat gbt
exists guys feed it into the machine chat GP
teacher ha it's a tally 13 14 something happened
13 times when it was supposed to happen 14 times
I hear 11 out of 13 8 out of 11 okay hey I
just so they're not hey what did I tell you
answer for helping I'm going to put a line
next to all them apologize to your brother
share your Legos okay I love you a there were
2,197 total events whatever they were but they
only succeeded 1,547 times oh look how many
times they didn't get the outcome they wanted
2,197 - 1,547 math rer 650 at 100K each it's
all connected somehow hands are for helping
you have brass knuckles in your pocket I got
a PAW Patrol Band-Aid in playground sent too
I am no longer my own man and you wouldn't
trade it for anything in the world not for
$65 million you are a changed man O'Donald $65
million you get like five kids and three lives
yeah so many houses and PAW Patrol Band-Aids
buy some land start a family be a good dad if
I had land I'd get four or five four or five
dogs no woman not even Dixon buy a Dix she's a
friend okay whatever you say that was some
dress though I love a dress I love a dress
I love a dress I like what the characters
do for Jack cuz he's he's more personal
and they could also get to his more vulnerable
aspects that make him tense up a little bit oh
you're all R up what can I say classical
music it cats my motor running really be
Razer let's have a little PR first you're not
messing around all right wonderful never know
how thick or thin to make these ladies
first oh no you did the work you get the
reward wow well played you got to
try before I can bring you on as a
dealer Co
no yes did not see that coming sweet they're not
my drugs which drugs the ones on your mirror or
up your nose best show ever and I know that
woman in the car wasn't Mrs Boyd and I have
a special distaste for people who don't
appreciate the sanctity of marriage yeah
because his wife died but when I ran your name
in the system is set off bells and whistles at
the local FBI office oh no they sent a
couple of their boys down here just to
talk to you and it seems they don't care who
your boss is oh yeah what up FBI fake lawyer
agent Jack margra oh never mind margrave this is
special agent Blake Lieutenant Oscar Finley Jack
margrave I just got that excellent Mar Graven
Blake boy we'll already have the story of a
senator's legislative director in the wrong
woman's car with a snout full of booger sugar
bger sugar so these charges they're not just
going to get swept under the rug we're not going
to let them one no way why cuz we don't like you
I don't even know why you're here we're here cuz
we want to know everything there is to know
about little wi fly on I don't know nothing
little wi is just a code name for what for a new
technology currently in devel velopment incredible
anti-missile software atomic bomb but a certain
Aeronautics company approached us let me guess
New Age yeah buddy they found the software could
be tweaked it could be used in missiles and not
just against them it could be scaled down and
installed in portable shoulder fired surface to
air Weaponry Jesus allows missiles to defeat
all known counter measures oh damn so we're
dealing with like like fullon arms dealers yeah
and weapons optimized to never fail completely
bypass their target making Pilots believe the
threat has passed and then they recalibrate
turn around zero back in on the aircraft and reack
like in dead the project required an appropriation
Bill Lavoy knew Little Wing would slingshot our
military into the future so I'm assuming Lavoy
didn't clear up the red tape in the most reputable
manner what do you mean I helped bury the proposal
in a thousand page statute while Lavoy shook
hands and drummed up votes and he did this
out of the the goodness of his heart to protect
democracy fat envelopes slipped inside newspapers
on park benches grow the up okay everyone made
fun of the Star Wars defense program but look
at where we are now everyone's trying to shoot
projectiles out of the air Little Wing can knock
anything out of the sky wow it's actually space
force your jackass yeah get it right new H has
two bases software made in New York Hardware at
a manufacturing plant in Denver Colorado no man
there's a lot of like crazy military [__] that
goes on Colorado I believe it welcome everyone to
Olivia and Greg's wedding here in beautiful below
0 deg Colorado so are the drug charges getting
dropped or what I don't know I'm not a cop nice
L of a surprise hearing you're wearing the badge
again Lieutenant no less yeah well retirement
didn't suit me good see you're still sporting
the Tweed what was it you told me when we first
met trouble always seems to find you amen you
kill a whole lot of people here and there you
still spin in that wedding ring got a new one
here and there a feeling better every day and the
dog Jack eat too much the dog dog's back or doing
well what are our directives you dicks and go
to Denver Ling software is useless without the
missile hardware and that's where it's made who's
tailing us Odon and I will head down to DC want
to swing by Homeland see what they know about am
you swing by Homeland I think we're just going to
knock on the door and say can the dod come out and
play my brother worked for Homeland his contacts
can help us that's right forgot about that how's
Joe doing these days he's dead yeah covered him
Dixon I feel an action scene is coming do you I
do I thought they were going to crash the car or
someone was going to crash into them a minute ago
so yeah you going to throw it in the garbage like
our sociopathic friend here borrow it oh yeah here
you go are just going to fight a random biker game
yeah we heard you're the biggest guy in town and
we're here to establish dominence hand over your
guns what makes you think we have guns we were
told you'd be packing Reacher packing Reacher
pack reach he beat us he did it for us yeah
they also tell you you die tonight they said
you were smart I'm going to cut you got you
you don't mess with the oneth man haven't you
heard oh yes yeah don't mess with the special
investigators [__] hell yeah boy oh yeah
he's got the nucks no does he have him right
now he's always got him with his paw patrol
Band-Aids damn perfectly timed
Deni oh good elbow chain is such
a cool weapon and he just damn damn
the way she uses them elbows are
great he head butt it broke his elbow God and that
leg Bend oh double leg Bend why are you hurting
them so much well they got pipes and chains
and [__] I guess it's even oh no no not the
hot one in the dress yes with heal she said she
was going to do it to somebody what a brutal ass
fight or I guess NE said it but still someone
delay good stunt work damn that was a brutal
fight yeah before you ask if it's
done it is you're causing a very
complex operation a lot of problems $65
Million worth Langston assume that's who
I'm talking to at a security why don't we
make a deal I have the means to give you
anything you could ask for what is it that
you want oh I want to throw you out of a
helicopter yeah dude I would have asked for four
to five dogs but whatever but five dogs and then
I throw you out of the helicopter not a house I
want a rental yeah under a different name give
me a an airliner and I'll just haul it on my
back I like the use of the music this episode
too yeah man yeah dude I got a lot of positive
thoughts on that one I generally do I really do
but not before I get out the positive thoughts
oh on today's video SP thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use news for our
merch store and is our gamechanging partner
in eCommerce so whether you're launching a
passion project or scaling to new heights
Shopify is e-commerce Powerhouse guiding you at
every step from creating your first online store
to opening physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're selling
exclusive merch or unique Collectibles thanks to
their all-encompassing platform for both online
and inore sales their checkout system unmatched
it's 36% more effective at converting visitors
into buyers than other platforms and let's not
forget Shopify magic the AI to that elevates
your business with minimal effort but seriously
reflecting on your journey using Shopify for
www.re naations shop.com it's been transformative
the transition smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying sales
to scaling our offerings Shopify has been a
Cornerstone of our success and Shopify isn't just
for us it Powers 10% of us e-commerce backing
businesses big and small and over 10075 countries
there a war-winning support always there to guide
you so ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at shopify.com
reex all overc case shopify.com reex start your
Shopify success story now let's grow together
with Shopify team big thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video a real game changer I've
been using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about expressvpn
for online privacy and security but there's more
to it than that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing down my
internet and contacting me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my new
laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I was
paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years ago
that made expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what you heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content of over
100 countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open Express VPN switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com reex and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to expressvpn.com
reex to learn more thank you again I really like
this one a lot that's my favorite one of the
season so far favorite yet yeah it really
brought it's because we had a returning character
from season one yeah I didn't like any of this
until Finley showed up like it all makesense now
if you just get Rosco oh wow oh dude you never
know you never know you never know what could
happen endless possibilities of Television PR
Endless Possibilities uh no even before that I
was it was Dawning on me in the way they bicker
in the restaurant at that very opening scene that
they are the best ones to cast out in Reacher's
mind you know because they know him the best so he
feels simultaneously the most comfortable yet they
can Pro poke and prod him the way that uh could
hit a soft spot better than anyone else whereas
you know last season you're exposed to a bunch
of characters where you just know he's in like
in control he's in charge and whatever they have
to say about him probably wrong yeah they probably
have no idea whereas these are the people you got
pain Reacher what is it underneath that pain you
know other than that yeah so this is like people
who definitely respect and look up to him but also
have been with him long enough to to be able to
see him in a way most people can't yeah because as
much as he's the leader of the operation he still
wants to always be equal with them so the way they
like uh just with each other I think is really
strong so yeah no I me I I really felt like the
core chemistry of the cast really Shine the Light
I feel like it finally caught up to my emotions
here yeah and the that's a really big mystery at
hand last one was you know a small town smuggling
or whatever and don't really remember the details
and this one's like we could destroy a country
you know we could we could any Target we won we
could win any War this is like much bigger uh much
bigger money at play as well so it it's it's cool
though I I I liked everything uh about this one I
thought the chemistry was solid I like watching
them out in the field being undercover and then
of course getting the down and dirty fight at
the end like we a lot of the things that I I've
not been diving into the comments admittedly on
Reacher one and two two one through three reaction
only because I know how these things go all right
I see the way audiences are loving things and here
we are having like yeah we're enjoying it but
we're not as in love with it I know that I qu
so we getting a lot of crap in the comments so
I'm like why would I waste my why would I expose
myself to that unnecessarily and and uh there's
one thing to like engage and have a discussion
with a discourse or whatever it's another thing
when you're diving in through a plethora of
YouTube comments that I'm just going to assume
are there U and and I I'll say though that the
emotion get people killed ions do get people
killed you need all the details yes or whatever
what's the line Details Matter Details Matter I I
think and then had a realization that details do
matter in investigation oh my God guys there are
these whole things called Clues all assembled of
these details is that what you call them explain
to me specifically in depth what is a detail what
do you mean there's not just one detail there
are many kinds of detail how many details do I
have to keep track of is there a finite number
of details break it down to me at its molecular
core what is a detail bring me a definitive
detail so I can just understand the basic
principle you can't just look at anything and
say it's a detail that's the point of detail
no Details Matter uh they do they do everything is
the details oh yeah yeah that that was really that
was I just like I I don't know I just really
like the style I felt kind of that New York
Vibe and and it felt like there was a kind of a
more unique personality to it I wasn't even like
thinking about the action until we got to the
moment where oh I feel like an action scene's
coming yeah I think that's I think in the most
simplified way that is what I often hope for from
this show in particular a show like this is yeah
to be engrossed no matter what is happening and to
be just as engrossed by the you know relationships
and the figuring out of the mystery even if some
of that figuring out is you know very kind of
Rapid Fire and details are sort of like oh you
got to grab like there's certainly moments where
and we joke during the episode and yes if we were
completely silent throughout the entire thing it
might be easier to catch every little detail but
those moments this video would also constantly
get blocked in copyright yes and there would
be very little footage C wa yeah exactly so
you know uh but yeah like those moments where
people would clarify I got a I mean I I real it
dawned on me yesterday I got interrupt and part
of the interruption is what I'm going to say
is what's the rest of the interruption just
this part explaining it is that uh I you know
I were you officially diagnosed yet ADHD or
add were you actually diagnosed or were you just
suspected I was like yes I've been diagnosed twice
yes that's how I know for yes after much going
around with many many professionals what do you
have ADHD okay yeah I've been diagnosed with ADH
depression anxiety here are all my issues well I
wasn't asking for the whole like problem history
John I Wasing about one thing Jesus dial it back
you were asking about Jesus it's your victim Jesus
was the Savior born in Bethlehem right around this
time of year except really in April we is that uh
this fast thinking mind is I we have a a our mind
is constantly thinking of things all the time it
doesn't stop doesn't turn off we're like creater
that way and and we're able to utilize that
VI reaction the things that we often Reserve
to ourselves out of politeness and knowing that
in regular day-to-day viewing experiences for
individuals that we would just get on their
nerves with the amount of thoughts that we'd
be sharing we now have an excuse to actually get
that out of our system yes because a that's what
is going through our mind and heart and B it
gives something to cut away to to feature the
reaction to get the requisite 8 to 10 seconds
you're only allowed for a clip so yeah yeah and
and and we also I mean you know these are all
happening off the to maintain the sanctity of
the first reaction you know these are all just
whatever were whatever we got in the moment so
you better hope you got good observations good
commentary good Joker and good rhymes for Jack
Reacher in the moment yeah man and sometimes all
I saw was the top comment of the last one and I
said I am not going through the Wormhole of these
comments yes yes no and that was all about they
run out of puns I even cut out the whole thing
about when you said Jack crowbar the whole thing
was cut out of when I was like crowbar John what
hasn't even what is there's not even a rhyme there
yes Jack Reacher and Jack crowbar aren't that far
away because they don't rhyme they're in the same
meter but we have established but but okay we
have EST you must admit Jack Reacher and Jack
poacher don't rhyme just because there's a chur
at the end doesn't make those Rhymes though so
like it's really hard to get because you always
need an eer rhyme to make it truly rhyme they
rhyme better than crobar agree to disagree how
does crowbar because it still ends in an R it's
still a two- syllable word and so like wow
I didn't realize orange and St and it still
has Jack Jack on camera here I mean I'm going to
employ a little bit of his words y because people
Revere his technical ability and will accept
that rhymes can exist where they're not most
obviously presenting themselves and some of them
yes are going to be Duds some of them are just
not going to be amazing and I regret we have I'm
saying we have established we have established
through a whole season one that when we are pun
rhyming that's obviously very much like obvious
one syllable or the two a very clear distinctive
one syllable Rhyme or a two- syllable rhyme it's
like Jack Flack slack Rack Attack I'm giving you
once to hold on to for the future here attack is
a two word yes but it's the ACT part that the
average listener is going to pick up you you
know don't I'm just saying there's more ways to
do we are dealing with YouTube b is fair enough
I'll keep it Anthony F T we not this is that's
not who I'm drawing my pun game from yeah but
I think he can make an argument cuz he's talking
about music and lyrics we're making stupid jokes
that ride with Jack time now independent of my
viewership of the needle drop Channel I have
ascribed to the theory that poetry can be poetic
without rhyme so like I'm making the effort to
at least try and and make it like relevant to or
rhymable in a way but like it doesn't always have
to be a rhyme to to equate to word player poetry
I agree so I'm just going to stick to chur on a
fundamental level I agree go for a e the way
it is being conveyed to the audience sure as
the top voted comment yeah no I mean I'll take it
I'll after a while you can't just blame everyone
else I'm not going to anymore intern go something
that we are looking that's the challenge but yes I
know shouldn't we challenge the audience these J
these stupid silly jokes wor they're challenging
by Me by me coming down on this I guarantee you
whoever made it this far there will be comments
being like I'm with John on this one that's
all I that's all we've done we've opened the
door man but but in seriousness fine like I'll
take the note we needed the conversation in the
attempt to pun and I'll only release the cream
of the crop no I held back on Happ we needed to
have the that would that would weirdly work that
would work a good it doesn't need to be it can
be four syllables but if it ends in a chur we've
accomplished it so the CH is the real key to the
ride I really think it is honest for the average
listener accept I will accept that that may that
those are the you were like oh I want to I want
to learn how to write a rap I think people would
start with that kind of mentality right they would
look at the chur but I agree I think they will
quickly learn that if they only use the chur as
the rhyme they will soon go well the first halves
of all these words are like totally different and
it's not as impressive because a million words
end in chur just like there's beser well anyone
who's doing anybody who does an activity is an
ER of some kind or like weaker yeah Bleaker peer
sneaker yeah so those I think I don't think has a
chur but you can add ER to anything is my point
I know I know I made that point in last season
when you were pulling that [__] and I said no
John we must challenge the audience it's an Ora
Boris well I have some positive thoughts on the
episode it doesn't matter anymore we're done
I will I will manage the on the puns definitely
talk so much more about I will try and bring my
better better game to that however all we have to
do is bring it up and then now you have a rise of
defenders in your corner and now we can do both
secret way to to yeah call engagement for these
videos uh no I really liked this episode and I
agree I I liked I was happy with the episode and
I'll find a way to shoehorn that into the next
reaction I didn't mean to Flack Reacher you here
Sean it's okay man uh I I take it back Reacher
anything I might have said to uh you know defy
oh oh I just thought of a good one for oh okay uh
feel I don't forget it but I thought of a perfect
one I'll just say it would have been great for
when when Jack and Dixon were doing it in the
bedroom ooh okay come on do you know what I think
so do you want me to to levy my guess I mean yes
okay uh riddle me this how clean is it because
I have a clear idea I think works because they
were in the sack Reacher that's it okay all right
all right all right all right good then we yes
that is a good one all right next do it at scene
sack Reacher yes call her here uh but but uh you
know to get back Reacher to discussing Reacher
episode for I no I I this has been a steady kind
of incline of yeah it's taken these each episode
seems to clarify kind of what the season is going
for and I'm getting more and more on board with
that as we go and this episode had the best like
calcified Ensemble like I was really getting into
like you said the rhythm of all of the main four
of them and uh and yeah even though there are so
many of these details that are like a lot to keep
track of and you've got these names of companies
and and you know different incidental characters
and then different important characters and
things like that it's thought uh the way that
they hardened by deposition or conversion into
calcium carbonate or another insoluble calcium
compound uh oh I you know something is made
material something is like made does that fit
am I misusing this word say read read the I was
trying to correct you I don't I didn't know what
it meant so look at that well now I want to see if
I used it right Hardon by deposition or conversion
into calcium carbonate or another I was going
to type it on the computer but yeah it's like
something BEC reasonably far away solidified uh
maybe somebody a vocab nerd can jump in but yeah
it's like their chemistry and their Dynamic
gets more solid the more time chemistry John
the purest chemistry uh Johnny let the actors
cook uh yeah like all the four main ones uh
you don't spend that much time with the cop but
I like again him whenever he busts through I'm
always pleased to see him and there's always
I can feel the scene he's having even though
he's off screen like whenever he pops in and he's
like pissed off at them I'm like I can see what
your day is probably like such a New Yorker yeah
and I love that and and I'm really enjoying that
as part of this because like we're not spending
that much time like soaking up the city and part
of me I I waver on that CU part of me is like
we've done New York in all of Cinema a billion
trillion bazillion times and so even though part
of me is like would be cool to see like how this
world immerses in it I I feel like we still are
in a way especially going into like Upper Crust
politics and things like that and then well I
think fish out of water is a natural is like
I think one of the best audience hooks you can
ever do sure you know because even if you're Jack
Reacher who's Mr Mystery Mr in control yeah yeah
uh because he's still Fish Out of Water there's
something where you are on the journey with him
because fish Out of Water yeah and and um they
have completely removed that element yeah out
outside of what's Happening Here guys you know
it's not really a fish out of water yeah he he
he sticks out everywhere but not in the same way
he did back in Mar grave in New York no one's
going to be like whoa look at the giant walking
what Beast stalk did you fall out of yeah yeah he
he Blends in a bit more and I think it's a nice
fun kind of subtle choice to yeah bring in his
peers who can see him and and who can foil him
in a way we're not used to seeing him foiled
so much in in an emotional sense more than a
yeah a physical or an even like cunning sense at
least that we know of so far well I love how much
they question him and how much it seemed to really
make you could see in Alan Rich's performance yeah
that what is it uh he he doesn't waver in his in
his belief when he believes he's you know in when
he feels like he's right about something yeah
I know the content of Swan's character I don't
believe he would go this way no matter what
but he gave enough of a shade of a doubt in
his performance to show and only this team could
kind of get to him on that yeah and it shows the
the that yeah it's like that's a a a a well-worn
it's like it's been built up over so much time
so it's not like fragile in that sense but it
is like yeah this is a tenuous line you know
casting doubt on one of our own freaking yeah it's
tempestuous man [__] it's all right uh but yeah
like M there just the fact like he's so adamant
against it but he's also not like uh like flying
off the handle but he's still just kind of taking
the feedback and not like completely shading the
team or making it some kind of meltic thing it's
like he's clearly steadfast in his belief in his
gut instinct about you know the things that
are going on the circumstances um but yeah I
like the way they handle those Shadows of doubt
and especially in this episode I thought it got
pretty engrossing as to just like yeah what okay
so clearly these two companies are together I want
to believe that Swan you know sees the risk that
uh this little wing program presents right right
and uh and you know is trying to you know send
messages from the inside the Hendrick thing um
you know and you hope for that and I have to feel
like because he looks so suspicious in that scene
where they're at the car with the bricks and
they're like Hey where's this extra brick of
drugs that just like fell out into the you know
space below your seat I guess like yeah it's it's
I I like the way this episode breath failed to
uh track Reacher hey failed to track reach of
the drugs under the back seat this is being used
in the review this is so it is allowed to be used
again in further reactions yes it's a touchstone
back to the moment in the episode yeah it makes
yeah it's these are these are appendix we will
act like we thought of them for the first time
there yeah totally totally totally yeah if you
stick around for the reviews next reaction you
know you'll feel a little included on some special
[__] um but yeah uh I like all that stuff and I
like the am am guy even though it is the most
broad part of this particular story in a story
that again not to keep being like the first
season but like they seem to establish that
the tone of the show wants things to be pretty
tangible pretty real and that's part of the fun
is that Jack Reacher and his crew but especially
Jack come off kind of super in some way like oh
man like yeah this guy is a a big buff Sherlock
Holmes of sorts um but uh uh uh oh goodness I had
a train of thought just like totally you were
saying that Jack showering in the bathroom is
one of like Life's greatest cinematic things ever
the the broadness yeah like it it even like even
though there is still like a magic in a certain
level of height to what the show is doing uh it
is like kind of beyond the sort of realism that
they seem to want to maintain when it is like I'm
in I need to do I need to figure my way out of
this identity pickle bus bench guy just going to
immediately go see him I'm going to immediately
kill him and then I'm going to take his glasses
and I'm going to leave you got to think about the
timeline of it guys we got a problem no I've got a
solution yeah I'm going to kill this man take his
identity I get myself out of this predicament yeah
this plan will be delayed by a couple days I just
need enough time to find a good person who looks
just like me to assume their identity and like
I enjoy the thing is luckily I enjoy it's funny
cuz we were just watching on patreon Supernatural
and it almost made me think of that cuz there's
an episode where there's a scenario that seems
like they're going to do a fake twin brother
Neil um yeah fake twin brother they're going to do
Nephilim uh and they were going to do a Nephilim
yes I thought he was going to summon a Nephilim
that's right rip a hole in time and space find an
alternate Dimension where like Jack reer like this
am guy is something else oh boy yeah yeah uh but
no it's it's one of those things that's like
it's a Trope and especially it's a film Noir
thing or at least to me it reminds me of stuff
like dark passage where it's like oh you know
the The Drifter who's either a pi or or a Hitman
or whatever who CH got his face changed like I
I appreciate the tradition of Noir storytelling
that comes from but at the same time it is very
much like it kind of undercuts I'm I'm not sure
actually I don't know it gives this Mystique 2
a.m. and so like it's it's kind of Broad and he's
so good at what he does and he's always cool and
calm and he's got the comic books and stuff like
that so like there's a lot of details and flavors
around that character but it is still like the
most kind of broad element and I think it's still
it's not taking me out too much because it's not
the majority of what we're watching um right now
the only thing that I would say is you know
I think expecting to fear for Jack Reacher is
life is uh a ridiculous ask of the audience like
I would never impose that feeling onto myself or
anyone else um fear for who he loves yes or who
he's concerned about cares about and right now if
any of them died on the team I'd be like that's
sad but if someone came up and shot Finley yeah
I'll would be so hate crime what is this stop
everything and go kill that guy yeah uh I would
I I would I I I I wouldn't like ne's one but the
others actually you know I'm breaking it down I'm
like pretty bummed if Dixon died honestly I'm
getting to the point where I'd be bummed if
Dixon or o Donell died yeah and O'Donnell with
the dad qualiity I think really and O'Donnell
in this episode was was particularly fun but
also showed his worth as I started saying it I
was imagining them ding I was like hey actually
you know what I guess I'm out of not none of of
them to the degree I I guess that is the one thing
because I was there really early on for for neie
and and Rosco and first season yeah where if any
of them died or or like they I was so concerned
for them and because you're not concerned for Jack
Reacher's life but they them I was concerned for
yeah and with these guys like it's their lives
who are on the line and I'm still nowhere near
there I won't be devast yeah I would be bummed I
will care but it is the thing where I feel like
this season has had a more kind of steady build
alongside the immediacy of the mystery and again
the circumstances make sense to why but I feel
like in the first season you had more pronounced
introductions to characters uh whereas here yeah
everyone's kind of crashing together and they're
like we're doing this kind of mid investigation
so it just moves different and that's fine like
I don't mind that and I'm liking this increasingly
so I assume that by the end you know I might love
this in a whole kind of different way from the
first and I and I like when contrast like that
can happen and I am happy to give a show like
this that kind of patience to develop that uh
yeah it's I would like to be at a point soon
where I'm like no and when I and when we go to
season three then be like you know I think back
on Rosco and Finley and those characters and I
want to think back on these guys if we don't see
anybody other than I assume neie will kind of be
a through line until she want I guess I'm just
not as super emotionally invested in any of them
yet but I am this was the like I I I was noticing
like oh when we're cutting away from Reacher I'm
actually really enjoying it yeah yeah yeah and it
was the first time that it was really occurring
for me uh with this cast of characters so yeah no
I I'm still I'm still having a lot of fun and I'm
really enjoying and this to me was fun engaging
and overall uh more the Jack reer show that I I
was really grew very fond of but guys what do you
think about it leave your thoughts down below be
sure to leave a like subscribe thank you to
our sponsors uh we'll talk to you all soon
bye clap Reacher no John no that
works